good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is a nice enough Friday here in New
York City the beginning of a long
weekend for a lot of us hey Claude hiya
derm I'm doing okay thank you so much
for asking
I'm it as a happy and bright Friday
morning here in New York City I have
left my house you know in two weeks and
whatever you know there's really nothing
to say anymore there's nothing to say
anymore but I'm excited that this
weekend is different from all other
weekends because it is a long weekend
we're not doing a show on Monday we
should have been at camp toast right now
and for that like my weekend will have
this cloud over it of like the camp
toasty vibes that aren't happening that
are like happening in a parallel
universe but not in this universe um but
I'm excited for a three-day weekend in
the cute like yeah no it's like a
three-day weekend in the Q is like good
I guess cuz like you don't have to like
set an alarm or like spend your day
zooming but I don't know something about
it makes me even more sad knowing like
the potential because if this was a
regular three-day weekend like I would
be hitting the town oh my god we would
have big big plans Oh actually we would
have been at Camp DOS we turned Vegas
plan to look at mall I know that's
really killing me and like now my time
hop is giving me so many like camp toast
feels and it's devastating yeah I hope
that I'm able to get some sunshine this
weekend maybe another sunburn like that
would be so exciting it really my
sunburn has faded but um the memories
have not and I'll never forget my time
in the Sun and I would I'd like to go
back there yeah that's the thing about
memories they never fade no unless
you're like me and they always fade cuz
you don't remember anything right or but
like the good ones day I feel like now
would be a good time for me to remind
everyone that my comedy special is
available for pre-order on iTunes it's
available at the link in my bio on my
girl with no job Instagram thank you to
everyone who has purchased it and left a
review if you want to leave a review
that would be great um it also would be
a great time for me to remind you what
today's word of the day is oh yes please
Prine p r e n preemie vibes the
definition being of a bird to grow with
the bill especially
rearranging the barbs and barbules of
the feathers and by distributing oil
from the European land okay so this
merriam-webster wondered a word of the
day for Mary Webster's not gonna work
for us because these are too obscure for
words like there are still so many words
that we don't know that are like actual
real big words we don't need to be
learning about birds of a feather flock
together okay but that definition is
like really um weird the other
definitions make more sense it's to
dress or to smooth oneself up like to
primp or to make oneself sleek so like I
don't know I'm gonna hit the town I
might as well preen myself this doesn't
sound nice like if I'm gonna say preen
and I'm two letters in I'm gonna say
primp no totally preen is like such an
unnecessary word but we know I don't
argue with merriam-webster I don't know
she's sometimes like she's a funny one
but I feel as though we need to consider
our sources I feel like the
merriam-webster it's like she's been
doing word of the day for years now so
she's like all out of words and we're
just at the beginning of our word of the
day so I feel like we could have more
accessible words okay I'll look into an
app but for today let's at least try to
get preen in there well I definitely pre
and myself up this morning because it's
just it's been like my my current crutch
in the queue is doing my hair lipstick
makeup like it's just something to do I
think I went about two months just
forgoing my looks and I got over it
pretty fast
yeah I have not gone over it that's like
the one benefit of quarantine for me is
I never really like doing my hair and
makeup so not having to do it for zoom
it makes me feel better but the fact
that like you're now on this glam like
moment I'm sorry you're now on this
print
moment um it's a little annoying because
it's just only highlighting how ugly I
am and how frizzy my hair is you know um
no I mean like I disagree I think that
you look great and at least you're not
like stuck with my lipstick on at the
end of this and having to like deal with
that that is true having to deal with
the consequences of a matte lipstick but
to each our own Club and you know it's
just at the end of the day it's whatever
it takes to get you through the queue no
judgments this is a judge
Freezone well it's really not but um
who's judging you no no like not me like
I'd spent this show like judging other
people that's like the whole premise of
the show oh I guess I guess yeah so for
those who are tuning in we are going to
recap Real Housewives of New York today
which aired last night and this week's
episode of Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills that was on Wednesday that we
didn't get a chance to recap yesterday's
so those will be at the end of the show
in addition to delivering you know
everything you need to know yeah and I
think I think it's time we can get right
into it
let everyone head out on their long
weekends you know full of fabulous
barbecues fire pits pool parties
whatever you guys are dealing with those
of you who don't live in New York City
bless you so jealous of you okay so
let's get into it without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast I've
made to say great the first story is
really some big music news it definitely
framed how I got ready this morning
because rain on me Lady Gaga and ariana
grande unleash a diva monsoon their new
song is out there's been a lot of hype
we know the Lady Gaga record comes out
soon I think it's next week but in the
meantime she dropped her re on a collab
and it's a big song and it doesn't
disappoint in my thing you know it
doesn't disappoint by any means I just
thought it would be like a little better
it's by no means a bad song I just have
a very high bar for Lady Gaga especially
when she's in her element like dance
club rape music and to me this song just
lacked a little bit of like substance
like there was no real like drop I'm not
just like waiting for something to
happen it was still a good song and I'm
jam out to it but I just thought like I
just I don't know my expectations were a
little high yeah I I really liked it I
didn't really have expectations cuz I
assumed that it was gonna be overhyped
and that there was no way that the Lady
Gaga an ariana grande song that winds up
dropping is gonna be everything that I
needed to be so I kind of had leveled
expectations and when I heard it I was
just so excited I think it's so good but
I've only listened to it a handful of
so I don't know yet and this is how we
felt about stupid love like I've
listened to it a few times it seems like
a nice song I don't know how I'm gonna
live with it yet and stupid love like
it's just so much better than I ever
thought that it was after hearing it a
few times so I believe that this song
will grow on me I think it's exciting I
think now this music really symbolize
like a turning point in the queue where
it's like okay now we are turning
towards like dance and that anthemic
music like we are going down a positive
Road yeah it's very hard for me to
evaluate music upon hearing a song for
the first time like I feel like some of
my favorite songs in the world I
listened to and didn't like in the
beginning like it's I don't understand
people who can listen to a song and be
like it's amazing or it sucks like I
don't know how I truly feel about a song
until I I've heard it like five or 10
times no I completely agree and that's
why I don't understand music critics who
I do album reviews you know they get the
album they listen to it and you just
don't know a song until you know how how
sticky it is in your head yeah or like
how it's built like I just I hear a song
and I'm listening and like I'm not
entirely sure where the first starts
where the course ends like you need to
live with a song especially an album I
agree with some album critics like
that's the hardest job in the world and
at the same time like just critics in
general like art is so subjective like
what makes your opinion more valuable
than mine
yeah and time it's so funny I like I've
been I was listening to reputation last
yesterday and when it came out when the
whole album came out we loved the whole
album there were some songs that were
that we loved more than others but like
the songs that I didn't like I think now
are the best songs the ones that took me
the most time to fall in love but even
like look what you made me do at the
time it was kind of a letdown because
you know it builds and builds and builds
and then it's like not there but the
songs not about the chorus you know and
it just takes some wit time some time to
develop that wisdom to appreciate the
song for what it is no I mean and I
don't want to discourage you from ever
saying positive things about Taylor
Swift but I don't think Taylor Swift has
ever released a piece of music that
isn't phenomenal except for look what
you made me do like I think it's just
not a good song but I think that
it was meaning behind it for her like
she just needed to get the message out
like she didn't really care like about
anything else other than like what the
words were saying so I'll allow it and I
know some people like it I'm not saying
that this is by any means like fact I'm
just saying let him in like I think it
is a bad song I just think it was ahead
of its time I think we hadn't heard from
her in a few years we were so like when
we got a song for him her we didn't know
what the reputation era was gonna be we
just came off 1989 and like that's what
we got like this
angry sort of song and it took us years
almost to like figure out this song and
now with those years in my back pocket
like I think that song is so amazing I
think the whole album is just like it's
a like a love it's it's a song about
it's an album about cancel' culture like
I can't think about it it's anything
else like I think it is so person into
the times like she was a crusader
against canceled culture before any of
us even had the word cancel culture in
our vocabulary no I completely agree she
is truly like a an artiste na and a
philosopher and I'm getting to a point
in my life where I think that reputation
might be my favorite album a lot of
people are having that experience I've
been hearing that a lot with in the
fandom I'm so happy for you I love going
on a journey with music it's like
because sometimes like certain albums
while they may be good like you can't
relate to them yet you're not at that
point in your life or you're just in a
different place but sometimes like a lot
of music especially Taylor Swift like
her music is evergreen so you can go
back in her catalog and like go back to
something that you might not have
understood when it happened like now
you're living it and you can relate to
it you know yeah it's just it's so good
and that's why so that's where I'm at
with music and even though I like this
Lady gaga ariana grande song asked me in
three weeks
totally like I've been in at Lebanon s
so well like oh well ask me in three
weeks and ask me again in three years
will do I'll make a mark in my calendar
perfect thank you okay are you ready for
our next story it's a little development
from mary-kate Olsen Steve or saga
because she is a headed to the Hamptons
in a three hundred and twenty five
thousand dollar rental if
scuse me oh oh I'm sorry that made it
seem like the car she was driving to the
Hamptons was a $325,000 I'm like I don't
even know what kind of car you could
rent for that but you can rent a house
for that yes I'm sorry that was
confusing and also like maybe she is in
a $325,000 car but I know she's in the
$325,000 house she is headed to a luxe
Hamptons rental for the summer sources
told page six she just lost an emergency
petition for divorce and was seeking to
continue using the couple's Hamptons
home as well as their Gramercy apartment
and an East 49th Street address they
live on 49th Street it's not very like
chic for America Hey look she's a Soho
girl 49th Street it's just a random
street like no matter where you are in
New York City like some streets are
random on the east side but poppin on
the west side that's true but and 49
49th is just interesting but it also
depends like is it issued by the UN or
is she in Hell's Kitchen
she's East 49th Street so she's more UN
Turtle Bay vibes oh my god is she just
like a post-grad millennial living in
Murray Hill is mary-kate Olsen a Turtle
Bay Queen wait listen maybe it's just
like a property that like they own like
an investment property wait I'm sorry I
skipped over the first half of the
sentence well I said it but I didn't
register it she was continuing using the
she was trying to use the couple's
Hamptons home as well as their Gramercy
apartment and in East 49th Street
address so they live in Gramercy they
have a place in Turtle Bay it's still
weird still weird but that's not where
she's been like living her days
commuting to the row office from 49th
Street and for those who may not be
familiar with like the New York
neighborhoods there's just certain
neighborhoods that like where you live
says a lot about you like that's why I
feel like a lot of that doesn't
translate in Real Housewives of New York
like if you don't get it why everyone's
so annoyed with having to go below Canal
Street like if you live uptown like you
never go downtown and 49th Street
especially on the east side is lovely
it's very residential it's very um it's
actually quite affordable so it just is
weird like most rich people in New York
they live either like on the Upper East
Side Upper West Side Soho they have a
big loft you know Tribe
like certain areas are chic for
celebrities 49th Street turtle bay is
very much like a post grad after college
like Murray Hill I'm sure you've heard
of Murray Hill it's similar to Murray
Hill it's not particularly like edgy or
fabulous it's just like a nice place to
live and I when I think Americain Olsen
I just don't think of her in Murray Hill
but maybe because her husband's brother
was some sort of magician maybe they
they needed a place by the UN maybe yeah
I was thinking that too because he was a
diplomatic side yeah he was a political
figure yeah that is just so interesting
but no I think she was primarily living
in Gramercy and we're like Theo living
in the sack if you're watching on
YouTube Theo is about to plop down in a
sack he's finding his clop he went wow
that was beautiful to watch are you so
proud of like a school I mean he just
continues to shake up my world every
single day like literally last night I
took a shower with Theo and we sat down
on the tub and I cut his feet like he
had so much area isn't it hasn't gotten
a haircut in three months my tub is now
completely clogged literally with dog
hair I don't know how to get rid of it I
can't call handyman then took the shower
this morning the shat his dirty shower
water is filled up to the top of the
bathtub I'm fired
that sucks speaking of hairy creatures
oh um a little redheads update because
we talked about her hairy legs on this
show ad nauseam Dana got rid of her leg
hair I'm not gonna say shaved because
she actually merde oh you know there is
a good product yes she was concerned
that like a razor would just break in
the face of her legs so she's really
there and she I know that I actually
said she she's a Billy razor but she was
adamant about using their and and it
really worked for her and I think now
she's like converted to using their for
everything which is injured wooden when
I was in high school I like tried using
their wands it smelled so bad like I
remember we used to share a bathroom i
stunk up the whole house it's a good
product but there is a fatal flaw in the
smell
an interesting product because it's kind
of a great idea but why don't more
people use it because I've heard a lot
of people having like negative reactions
to it like if you have any type of
sensitivity when you're when it comes to
your skin like you're breaking out and
you're getting red dots and it's your
legs feel like they're on fire that's me
I have every sort of sensitivity when it
comes to my skin yeah well when I first
used it I was so self-conscious about my
upper lip and like middle in high school
and I wasn't allowed to do anything
about it so I like secretly bought an
air at Duane Reade and like tried to
near my lip and I did get quite a burn
from it because I left it on for too
long so um now I just wax it all the
time oh and I also have it right here
I've got this little facial hair remover
it's from Amazon it's called the
something and it's fabulous I use it all
over my face nice okay well oh this next
story is some interesting news some
interesting like industry news then one
get your thoughts on okay
John Krasinski's show some good news
cells to Viacom CBS following a massive
bidding war so John Krasinski started
this feel-good web series um in the
queue and apparently it was for sale and
there was a big bidding war and now it
would sold to buy come CBS and the
series will have a multi-platform
showcase across all the conglomerates
brands through the actor writer producer
indirect though the actor writer
producer and director will no longer
host it so he won't be hosting a show
anymore yep but like the idea of some
good news just like was this
revolutionary idea that um is now sold I
can't explain like why this bothers me
so much but it just I think if I were to
even try to explain why these types of
formats like even Miley Cyrus is bright
minded which they all have good
intentions I'm not saying any of these
people are bad people they just set out
to like make positive content and do
good things with their platform and I
really respect and appreciate that but
to me it's just like stay in your own
[ __ ] lane it's like they're generally
[ __ ] huge Digital shows there are
that don't get
by Viacom and have been going on longer
than just the quarantine like it's just
how is anyone in the digital space ever
really supposed to get ahead when
celebrities are just like taking over
HBO Max and she has a cooking show
Selena Gomez like it just they're
spreading themselves so thin and I
bothers me so much and I don't know if
I'm just jealous which is very very
possible but it's just like it seems so
hypocritical to me where it's like
there's two types of celebrities there's
like traditional celebrities and digital
celebrities and I think for a while and
there still is it's like if your digital
celebrity it's like you're not really
that ælis it's like you're always a step
below but now it's like these
traditional stars are just coming in and
taking our jobs yeah I I agree with what
you're saying something about this just
like rings annoying to me and it's not
even it's not even jealousy think it's
like this like it's just completely even
though I'm like advocating for a digital
web series which is technically what we
do like I'm just not thinking about
ourselves at all um but it isn't like he
comes in makes one show one day like
there are so many different digital
shows and like it just and there's this
like massive bidding war as if he's
reinvented the wheel invented a web
series not to mention it's not even the
most original idea and I don't even know
who had the first you know idea for a
positive but like to me this sounds like
a ripoff of the Instagram page takes
good news
I just soaked up and was literally just
built to put positive news out there
like there's so much negativity on the
internet and people love it like it's
only been around for like one or two
years but it's grown it has millions of
followers and to me this seems like a
[ __ ] ripoff I completely agree when
when I first saw his show I just heard
thought of tanks good news and now I
agree like he didn't invent a web series
and he didn't and then like talking
about good news so why is this such a
revolutionary idea that media
conglomerates are clamoring for no and
you won't need the more that I think
about it the more that I realized this
entire thing is a ripoff of like tank
Sinatra's entire brand like he does all
these videos like he talks a lot about
mental health it has a huge focus on
like positive news and here comes John
Krasinski stealing taste goods news his
job yeah well John Krasinski won't be
hosting it which is like weak so then
why did you
i-it's like it's not a new idea it's
just a famous host that people like so
you're not even gonna use the famous
host that people likes and I was just
going off of this like old idea that you
didn't have to buy his show to have this
idea maybe they will get ting Sinatra to
host it and then all would be well
yeah to me this is like this whole story
is just indicative of like how
antiquated certain media companies are
like they can't even be for thinking and
the only way they'll ever do something
is like if the celebrity's attached to
it like and by the way there are people
who [ __ ] love John Krasinski I don't
even know if they would watch a show
like I didn't I hadn't even heard of sgn
until tik-tok made they did a huge
partnership with him and he was like the
first video on tick-tock like the ad
when you open the app so I hadn't even
heard of it until then
so tick-tock invented John Krasinski is
what you're saying essentially I wish I
could put into more clear words like why
this bothers me so much and I'm so
curious if this bothers other people as
much as it bothers me because I can't
really explain it it's just like stay in
go away you look it the [ __ ] away yeah
no it bothers me ultimately I just show
about good news and I'm sure it'll be
good um but just there's something here
that's like no let's get out yeah listen
to Joe Joe leave get out right now
the end of SG and it still they and I
can't wait for John to be gone love okay
just a little trail for you are you
ready for our next door because it's
[ __ ] hilarious
yes ma'am a 25 year old Sephora employee
from California has been fielding calls
and texts meant for Elon Musk for years
now having been given his old recycled
cell phone number by AT&T Lindsey Tucker
says she's received calls from the IRS
text with blueprints for a bionic arm
and requests to buy a Tesla cyber truck
she says her phone blows up every time
musk is in the news for doing something
controversial and she has to convince
people she's not Elon Musk this is a
hilarious story I love this story
because you know what I've always
wondered like I actually read a story
the other day that the Kardashians are
now on in a process of getting a new
phone number every
week and it's like where do those old
phone numbers go because phone numbers
are only seven digits in certain error
your area code so it's like at some
point we will run out of phone numbers
yes I guess but they're getting one
every week I mean I don't know if that's
true I just read it in like some blind
Oh cuz that seems like torture how you
gonna reconnect with old friends wish
someone a happy birthday
no totally but I guess it's like it's a
need-to-know basis like if I need to
wish you a happy birthday you probably
have my new phone number but every who
can keep up every week that seems
extreme maybe like every month or yeah
no it's just better this is fascinating
I've always wondered about it so um I
wonder if I have any ones like old phone
number well no your phone number is so
old that it was probably its first phone
number yeah it is interesting I mean you
love them that's cuz you a great one to
have but I'm sure celebrities had new
phones all the time therefore their old
numbers go up for grabs and I'm sure
people are just calling and calling
totally this is so interesting how did
she get how did this story come to be
like how do people know this um it's an
NPR I don't know if she like they found
her there she came forward or it's just
do you think that this is the first time
we've ever reported from NPR no I think
I've accidentally like found a way here
before because sometimes like I got this
story from my newsletter and daily links
on PR so sometimes if I were doing yeah
if I get it from my newsletter and then
I'll just go to the source really funny
okay fifth and final story Kelly Ripa
has been secretly been filming live
while quarantined in the Caribbean while
Ryan Seacrest was forced to take off
time due to suffering from exhaustion
his morning show host Kelly Ripa has
been picking up the slack from a house
and the Caribbean page six is told Ripa
and her husband and their three kids
have secretly been quarantine away from
their Manhattan home for the past few
months she's been filming ABC's live
with Kelly and Ryan from an island
hideaway friends are staying at the
family's NYC abode
while Ripa and the family are away
Seacrest is filming from his LA home a
source told them that the family was
already in the Caribbean when the
shelter-in-place order was issued in
March they made the family decision to
stay put despite her tropical location
Ripa has made it knows
that she's been struggling amid lockdown
tearing up on air as she as she told how
she's missing her parents and dealing
with unruly youngsters who won't hug me
would you like me to keep reading you
know I just want to know what the point
of the story is so she's been lying this
whole time and like pretending that
she's been doing live with Kelly from
New York and is it just now coming to
light that she's in the Caribbean and
are people mad at her for being in the
Caribbean this is the first time seeing
that she's in the Caribbean I don't know
that she's been lying and saying she's
in New York she probably just like she's
on a couch and we don't know every
crevice of her apartment so you just
assume she's right home turns out she's
been in the Caribbean and they were
there before the order which is kind of
funny to think about because I think
when the shelter in place happened so
many people were like oh my god I wish I
was on vacation I would just stay and
just be on vacation but like three
months later what happened to Jay Cutler
and Kristin Cavallari you just want to
be home yeah no totally I'm not entirely
sure like what I'm supposed to take from
this story but what I have taken is that
every time I read about Kelly Ripa like
I roll my eyes like all of her news
stories are so planted like whoever's
doing her PR is fabulous because they
get her in magazines all the time with
the most irrelevant like Kelly Ripa and
Mark Consuelos pretended to trick their
daughter into thinking that they were
getting to boy it's like there's
obviously some dumb stories and it's
it's a great like mechanism to keep her
relevant because she's in the news all
the time but like I just like I'm over
her like over her and her like like all
the press that her and her husband like
are always churning up for themselves
like and now they use the kids for
everything like kids graduating kids
going prom kids this like just I don't
care ideally Kelly Ripa and Mark
Consuelos daughter just graduated
college you'll never believe what Kelly
boarded her graduation no it's a I
barely care about Mark Consuelos and
Kelly Ripa I don't care one iota about
their children no but like I honestly we
need their publicists like they are
everywhere like overexposure and like
then that's when like the public starts
to resent people so people don't realize
what's been going on yet they don't
realize that they've been like
infiltrated with Kelly Ripa mindless
news no I but yeah that's that's what it
is it's
like I have never read a story about
Kelly Ripa that was actually substantial
or that really made me like know more
about her to me the most interesting she
thinks she ever did was storm off of set
and not return when Michael Strahan left
and to me that told me everything I need
to know about her yeah I totally want to
be great it's just like I know John
Krasinski has like some good news Keller
if I should have a show some mindless
news SMN yeah and networks can like
clamor over it like I I am I
there's nobody whose name appears and I
scroll by faster than Kelly Ripa like I
just know that whatever the storyline is
it's not important it's not substantial
it's not meaningful it's not
thought-provoking like it's just
silliness yeah
I completely agree and I hate to tear
down a fellow woman in media but like no
you're not out of control but like
you're not saying anything negative
about her like you're just flirting yeah
she just like hard work
ot yeah no or her PR team like someone
is just out of control and they need to
chill yeah I agree well I'm jealous that
they're in the Caribbean um sounds
lovely um should we dive into our TV
recaps Eggman because I've got so many
thoughts on Beverly Hills yes let's get
right into Beverly Hills it was just a
pleasure to watch did you agree that
there was just like the episode of like
fabulousness for Erica like her Chicago
thing her house Tom Girardi yes Tom
being there and like all of the girls
like meeting Tom and just listening to
Tom was really something special and you
could tell that like they really all
were impressed by him not that they
wouldn't be um but I also felt like a
little silly like they are we're like
schoolgirls like sitting around the
principles there no it literally felt
like when you go to your friend's house
and like she's out her parents house and
like you have to like wait in the lobby
like I mean in the living room like for
them and you're like hi mrs. Smith how
are ya
I totally felt like that weird
schoolgirl vibe for sure but I just love
Tom Girardi that I don't care like I
just need more content of him and they
did need him to meet Erica's friends
because I think Erica goes to him for a
lot of advice and just like tells him
what's going on with the women and he
needs the contexts like no Garcelle and
nice
and dr. Theodore Freeman is in the
background and he's just like on a
mission and I hope he gets where he
needs to go I agree I absolutely love
Erica's house like it's so glamorous
it's just don't know what you expect for
Erika Jayne but it's a party and I
didn't have a deep enough appreciation
for the outside of her house before and
like those two massive palm trees like I
just didn't ever really took stock of
those palm trees and then last night
like the palm trees were just like so
fabulous to me yeah and then the
production really lit them up like from
the bottom so that they could get a
whole picture of the house in the dark
it was quite stunning to me that nothing
happened before the dinner party like it
was just a lot of honestly silliness and
I was getting a little bored until they
arrived at the dinner party cuz that was
really everything of the sort um now I'm
struggling so hard because to me like
I'm just on everyone's side except for
Kyle and Sutton but Sutton really does
have like a legitimate gripe with to
read and jury won't let it go yeah and
now all I felt bad for Sutton because
all the women like even Lisa was like I
didn't know what you were gonna do like
it's making such a mountain out of a
molehill and I actually feel bad for
something like and Lisa Rinna being like
at my daughter's event like one she
didn't do anything to Kyle said she
didn't do anything so don't act like she
did to like you don't invite the women
of your cat of your crazy show cast to
come to an event if you're honestly
concerned that they might have a scene
because they're always having a scene
and that event for um Delilah and Amelia
was like so lovely but I'm pretty sure
that they were the only people there so
if they had like popped off it wouldn't
have affected anything and maybe their
clothing line would have made some
headlines because there was a Real
Housewives fight like honestly at the
end of the day nothing happened and even
if something had happened it wouldn't
have been the biggest deal of all time
like there are some events where these
ladies I cannot fight like it would be
so rude and so embarrassing that was not
one of those events
I completely agree so on the my cuts are
just flying the air pods are like we are
done we are working too hard in
quarantine my ear pods work like
literally seven hours a day in the queue
and they used to work like seven hours a
week maybe oh my god that was hard for
me to bend down under my desk what I was
going to say it was it's hard for me to
choose sides here because Kyle is so on
the right side of history when it comes
to Sutton she's like the only one who
could think clearly but then she's also
being like an animal to everyone and to
me she totally crossed the line and was
so unforgivable when she literally just
like lash out at Erica who was barely
involved and was like it's not because
you don't have any close friends like
are you kidding me that is such like a
season six narratives yeah I agree
it's like using the one thing she shared
with you once against her not cool right
that's why it's so [ __ ] up like when
you share something with someone and
you're vulnerable and then they use it
against you in a fight like that's the
most [ __ ] up thing but you know what's
bothering me and I'm not on Keio side
I'm very much on like dur each side um
but Dori keeps saying like all we want
is for Kyle to admit that she and Teddy
have a different sort of relationship
and different set of standards okay so
like say Kyle were to admit that what
does that change I just don't get the
point of this whole argument like you
want her to admit it so badly and then
what everything's gonna be okay she can
continue doing this with Teddy like
what's the point
almost ya know like what's the reason so
okay she acknowledges it and then what
right like you or do you want her to
change how she behaves towards all of
you and apply the same set of standards
to Teddy that she does to you
I understand maybe wanting that but some
friendships are just different and some
people bother me in other ways that
other people don't and like that's just
course being human but I think to read
is Riyaz responding to like Kyle just
randomly coming for her at Teddy's event
and really thinking like maybe if we
weren't at Teddy's event like Kyle
wouldn't have tried to put me on blast
maybe if he was Teddy the one who showed
up Clayton and gladly
she wouldn't be yelled at Teddy like
when she was being scrutinized I'm sure
she was just comparing like why are you
doing this to me you wouldn't do it to
Teddy yeah but now the argument has just
gone down this path of like what are we
really fighting about oh it's just so
that you admit that you guys did a
breeding exercise together and that you
wouldn't do that with someone else like
this big fight for that it's getting off
the rails a little bit yeah I'm curious
why denise is really gung-ho fur for
Kyle this season it seems like they just
often on the wrong foot and they can't
get back and I under it like honestly I
wouldn't know I would just like Kyle to
if she like came to my house and made
fun of my ice sculpture and then like
what's calling me like faked for showing
up in glam when like everyone shows up
in glam um but it seems like she's
really unhappy with Kyle like she wants
her out yeah it's I don't know the
reasoning behind it yet and when the
girls were in the car and I absolutely
loved Garcelle and I thought every point
that she made was so on point when they
were in the car and they were talking
about Kyle like yes it's not a nice
thing to do it's a kind of like mean
girly but when garça and like we've
gotten to this place when we watch TV
shows like it used to be like the meaner
you were on the show like you are our
hero like you know when they would go
after Danielle style but now ten years
later it's like you can't say these
things about Danielle it's just like
it's just changed which I think it's
really good because we're getting to be
nicer as people but with ourselves like
yeah we're being catty but that's what
you do with real girlfriends it's so
true like that's what I do with my
friends like if someone is being like a
shitty friend or a [ __ ] like or someone
we don't know like yeah we're gonna
[ __ ] talk about it because we're real
with each other and we just say how
we're feeling we don't like filter
everything that we say yeah I mean what
Garcelle said about Kyle's outfit was
mean because I didn't think it was so
terrible but Kyle has peed and deleted
something Oh what did she say and also I
wasn't talking about her making fun of
Kyle's outfit because that's not nice I
was talking more about them just talking
about Kyle's behavior like she talks at
us not to us like they were just getting
caddy in the car but like in a very real
way and like that's what real friends
sound like hailey party you leave a
party and you talk about all the weird
things that happened of course Kyle said
Garcelle snickering that my outfit is
hideous while wearing stretchy purple
knee-high boots with a pink suit dress
that her stylist picked for her I
thought Garcelle looked great
I thought Garcelle looked great too and
I loved her the clips in her hair I just
love Garcelle like I think maybe if she
showed up in like a dress made of duty I
would think it was fabulous like I just
love her and I just think she's right
like I'm just gonna be on to me she
reminds me of Erika Jayne like I just
trust their moral code and I think that
like whatever she whatever side she ends
up on or whoever she has a bargain with
like I just believe in her that she
knows what's right yes but I do need her
to get in the mix
a little more like I think all the
ladies I'd really like her and think
she's fabulous but she keeps getting
personal with the viewers um you know in
her home or with her friends but not
with the ladies yet so I need these two
worlds to come together and these things
take time so I'm not I'm not in any rush
but that is what she is missing from the
cast because I haven't seen she's gotten
a little deep with Ericka but I need her
to get deeper with the cast well I think
her telling Kyle that she feels glazed
over by Kyle was her was her trying to
do that like trying to get more involved
like I don't feel like you want to get
to know me but at the same time Kyle did
to be it like we we had only known each
other at this point like we've only met
a few times like so you can only get so
far in a certain amount of time but I
agree like I need her to divulge more in
the group yes and now for Sutton who is
really like just finding a warm little
spot in my heart I just I think she is a
really nice woman and she says what she
means and she's very sensitive but I
don't think that she's I think in the
first few episodes when she was like
doing this stuff with the seating cards
and like just being sort of strange like
it wasn't any sort of maliciousness at
all like she's just socially awkward and
I I will always relate to a socially
awkward Queen I agree and I think
production like set her up a few times
to say like cringy things about fashion
and all that and they just I yeah and I
knew when it was happening that she was
probably being stitched together poorly
but I just thought it was funny now that
I feel like I've gotten to know her I
feel like they definitely like set her
up to be cringy in the beginning yeah
and I can forgive all of that I'm
looking past it because now every time I
see her she's just like a different
woman to me and even in the car when
Teddy was like getting carsick just
Sutton's reaction it's like she's just
an interesting woman she doesn't say
what I think someone's gonna say and I
appreciate her she's very different from
all of the other women I agree I
actually feel bad for Teddy I thought
that like the way Kyle and Sutton
reacted that could have been a little
bit more nurturing to a pregnant woman
who's feeling not nauseous yeah I mean I
felt very much sympathetic for Teddy
like these blocks out in the front they
need to start like they need to break up
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills into to
cast like the
to live near each other and the ones who
live across town hear from each other
because like these long car rides are
making me queasy a great um now let's
talk about New York um
I just well I'm gonna start around hi
because I did something different last
night I watched New York while I
repainted my nails and doing some not
giving all 100% of my focus to New York
like wanting it to change my life but
like doing doing 50/50 made the episode
a lot better but it was yes oh oh d
Senedd right or maybe as I was just cuz
I was doing my nails it's definitely
better and it's because something's
happening or at least trying to happen
that I feel it has been necessary for a
while and that's Terrain de being held
accountable for being a horrible friend
and saying some of the most unforgivable
Ramona said jugular things and we didn't
even get close to that because to me
last night's episode was reflective of
how unreasonable Dorinda is and like how
she will never be held accountable for
anything that she says but it was
starting to happen like everyone kind of
realizing like I've it's funny cuz I'm
out I'm I am now this season for the
first time starting to like Dorinda
because for the last few seasons I have
just thought she's so unreasonable she
drinks way too much she says the meanest
most horrible things people and kind of
just gets this past from everyone
because she's like funny and cool but
now it's like I'm actually only starting
to like her now but it seems like the
group is kind of on to the fact like
she's really been the one for the last
few seasons like really stirring up the
drama and saying some of the most mean
hurtful things yeah I would agree and I
think Leah's really the perfect person
because her enduring us seem to have
mutual respect I think Lee is the
perfect person to bring a lot of this to
light especially in defense of Tinsley
um I enjoyed the Russian bathhouse that
looks like so much fun
maybe everything just looks fun right
now but that ginger vodka like looked so
good and it looks like a legit spa like
where you will go and get legit
treatments I don't know I was literally
dying at everyone's reaction to like the
outside of it because just like a place
where you get like a happy ending
and the inside was like better than what
I thought and I was glad that everyone
liked dobe head first into the
experience but like
come on Leah Productions paying for a
day at the spa let's go to the [ __ ]
Carlyle but I like that she got the
ladies out of their element
no I don't oh I liked it I thought and
maybe it's just cuz it was Leah and I
like everything that she does for sure
you know like I'm not gonna this is her
favorite spot it's my favorite spot too
now um what do you think about Ramona
pulling sonya aside and telling her she
needs to lose weight okay obviously that
is not acceptable period but these women
I mean this keeps happening these women
are from like just a different time you
know and like even though there are some
of them around the same age as the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills like the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills are
very much like Oh like part of the
culture you know they're on social media
like they're very much in it like they
know the way that the world is now but
like Ramona does not she lives in the
time period that she all derived in they
all live in the past and in the past
maybe that was an acceptable thing to
say to your girlfriend right he's not I
heard when I heard it I was like
Ramona's gonna get so much hip for this
but I felt like she said it in the way
that like your grandmother used to be
like hey why don't you have a salad like
I am not by any means defending her but
to me I agree they don't exist in this
world they don't know that like those
are things you don't [ __ ] say no and
like they're they're not even concerned
with what our viewers gonna think about
this like and that's what kind some most
of the time makes the show so great
they're legit just being ourselves for
better or for worse so obviously that is
not a thing that is acceptable to say
period but these women just live in a
different time period um where things
like that were things that you said and
Sonia is my [ __ ] favorite because she
literally was in the hallway be like I
love myself I don't care if I'm fat I'm
skinny I'm great no matter what and I'm
like a guest Sonia same love that but I
feel like I don't know so frustrating
because there's not clear alliances like
everyone like the fact that Sonia took
the written aside for like the first
time against Ramona Ramona was the
weirdest thing ever but then it was like
why the episode the series is like so
dry like they're desperate for content
why didn't we only see Sonia throwing up
in the band in a flashback yeah oh I
don't know also Sonia made a decision
early this season to take her in this
side no matter what because of what
she's going through um and I think it's
like this association it's like Richard
and their past and they both have that
and I think she just has made the
decision like whether it comes intensely
or even Ramona now like she's going to
bat for so Dorinda because she thinks
that Dorinda needs it and and I can
respect that I really did like how
Ramona though it went against her code
stood up for Tinsley and said Dorinda
you are being mean like this is
something I've been thinking about it's
been bothering me like you have a very
mean streak and of course during it
didn't take well to that but I was
really proud of Ramona just for doing
for saying the right thing even though
like she's always saying the wrong thing
she's always saying the wrong thing and
in a lot of ways she's like the
matriarch of the show she's the only og
and people respect her opinion and I was
shocked that she took Tinsley side I was
shocked that she stood up for her at the
bathhouse and then also again in her
apartment and I was glad that she like
went outside and made amends with Duran
in Sonja I brought them back because
nobody who needs like a divide like that
but I just think Dorinda is so
unreasonable like she should just be
given a pass and by the way I am so
sympathetic to like what people go
through and how it changes them and
affects them as friends and you can't
always be the best friend to someone
because you're going through your own
[ __ ] like I respect that but to be so
[ __ ] mean and say some of the most
vile things to Tinsley like my gum lasts
longer than your relationship you only
do things on your back like such a
[ __ ] mean vicious things I don't
think that going through a breakup or
trying to go through grief that doesn't
give you a path to say such mean things
to people yeah I completely completely
agree also those mean things that
Dorinda was saying to Ramona in her
apartment like you couldn't land a
boulder like and that's been like when
Ramona and I think that she has a really
thick skin because she dishes it out and
she takes it like she says crazy [ __ ]
and she receives crazy [ __ ] but like you
just watched her demeanor change her she
was so hurt like obviously that's
something that upsets her um and a
friend would know that that's what and
that's what she's saying
Dorinda goes for the jugular she knows
what upsets you when your insecurities
are and that's exactly what she did to
Ramona in her own [ __ ] apartment and
that scene in the apartment was
[ __ ] wild it was giving me like
season 1 vibes where they would just
like have cheese and stand around and
just fight with each other now they like
go to fabulous places to do it um
because the show has just evolved but in
the beginning it was just like come over
let's fight and with all those
variability conversation with all those
random ladies standing around like it
was just insane to watch well that's
what we have to talk about because as
much as it was a better episode than
usual it was completely ruined by Elise
she was bothering me so much in the
hallway like following the cameras
around come on let's go inside come on
let's go out here why are you wasting
breath shut up you're not the referee of
this fight no she kept like chiming in
it's like no let the conversation go
where it needs to go like stay out of it
I guess ultimately I'm glad she brought
them from the hallway into the apartment
because like it would disturb the
neighbors like that let the women be
like that's what the show is you just
put block them down and let them be and
she was just really interfering way too
much and I need her to like I need the
seek point in the season when they
realize she's not a full time cast
member to come when they like stop
including her and everything and I
absolutely love that Liana and invite
her to the bathhouse me too does she go
to Newport next week Rhode Island I
don't know I didn't see her there but it
doesn't mean she wasn't there
it was a better episode than usual I
don't he was better and next week looks
really good too Newport yeah so I don't
feel as disgruntled as I did last week
so I will let this one just to go to bed
yeah me too um it was a good week for
television and I'm gonna spend the
weekend reading more I think because I
spent last weekend watching on TV I just
started a new book that like it's so
interesting looking at I'm enjoying it
already I'm having a little bit of
regret for not choosing it for the
redheads but it's about vampires so I
know that's not like everyone's thing no
it's not but unfortunately I'm having a
Wi-Fi issue where like you're really
blurry for me so I'm just gonna wrap
this up okay okay
cuz I mean she did stop writing her hand
really hurt and she's like ready to take
the long weekend so let's do it
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium morning
sure when we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher public radio
radio cast box all the places so ever
you listen to podcast find us the
morning totally the five star view that
have beautiful stunning and smart we are
if you were looking for more content we
have tons of new episodes of our
podcasts and video vlogs up on our
patreon channel patreon.com/scishow
morning toast we also have brand new
episodes this week from all of our
tienen shows so follow at toast news
network for updates
make sure to preorder my comedy special
available on iTunes for pre-order right
now you can click the link in my bio on
Instagram and if you're looking to take
pictures of this weekend and look
fabulous as hell go to Jackie O Flow
calm to get Jackie's new pack of presets
they're her finest work yet we love you
guys so much we'll see you Tuesday
there's no show Monday have a great long
weekend stay safe I